[Musique]
j'étais politique ce matin c'est
philippe martinez bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
général de la cgt en étant 100 pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre redon bonjour fabrice bonjour
oriane des journaux du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france philippe martinez pas de
confinement et l'annoncent de jean
castex qui est arrivé quelques heures à
peine après votre rencontre en tout cas
la discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux ce que vous attendiez à une
telle décision
non non non non non c'est parfois le
gouvernement est imprévisible sur ses
décisions tout cas il y avait rien à
laisser penser que de telles mesures
allaient être annoncé en fin j'étais pas
personnellement à la réunion mais la cgt
y était c'était plutôt une discussion
comme d'habitude quoi pour eux c'est
quoi une discussion très mnemic et on
nous demande notre avis puis les
décisions sont se font souvent sans
notre avis c'était quoi votre avis là
nous on écoute les scientifiques on
écoute les scientifiques qui disent
attention il ya un risque de plus en
plus fort donc il faut le souci c'est la
santé donc il faut faire attention à la
santé
avec ce risque aussi que la santé c'est
aussi les risques psycho sociaux qui
existent à travers le télétravail
nous ce qu'on demande c'est quand même
d'avoir une visibilité à plus long terme
mais vous auriez préféré un confinement
les c'est ce que disent les
scientifiques
voilà pour il fallait écouter c'est ce
que disent les scientifiques et
j'entends que beaucoup de scientifiques
sont inquiets de ce qui peut se passer
en tout cas il faut avoir une vision à
long terme parce que on gère ça excusez
moi l'expression à la petite semaine un
peu c'est c'est le couvre feu après ca
un couvre-feu renforcer tout en nous
disant que tu aura peut-être un
confinement c'est anxiogène pour les
français je pensais donc il faut qu'on
ait des options d'ici on va cour fera un
point d'ici une semaine et y aura là
c'est ce qui est dit l'un pour le coup
vraiment on dit c'est la semaine des
saisies une semaine pour éviter druilhe
on finit lui est concrètement ce que
vous dites c'est que si la courbe
continue évoluer telle qu'elle évolue
vous suivez vous l'avis des
scientifiques il faut qu'on fini c'est
quand même les mieux placées même si
parfois il ya des voix dissonantes c'est
quand même les mieux placés pour nous
dire nous parler de la santé en même
temps le camping confinement riz été
rime aussi avec risques psychologiques
mais bien sûr c'est déjà le cas et on
voit dans le monde du travail mais aussi
sur les étudiants on voit qu'ils n'ont
pour certains n'ont pas eu de cours
depuis presque un an
est ce qu'il ya c'est que depuis un an
on a quand même on est on
on est soumis au chaud et au froid enfin
confinement c'était ça allait mieux puis
couvreux confinement couvre feu et puis
il ya le problème de la prod des
protections il ya eu les beaucoup de
débats autour des masques aujourd'hui
c'est la vaccination parce qu'il faut
mettre le paquet comme on dit sur la
vaccination on voit que des engagements
du gouvernement sont loin d'être
atteints
on va reparler main sur l'acceptabilité
de ce confinement vous voyez que par
exemple des restaurateurs qui malgré
l'interdiction veulent ouvrir qu'est ce
que vous dites à ces restaurateurs que
c'est une erreur mais je dis rien aux
restaurateurs ce que ce que je comprends
c'est que la la les règles sont pas les
mêmes pour tout le monde
voyez on nous dit c'est pas dans les
magasins compte qu'on est contaminée ou
qu'on chope le virus il ya un endroit où
enfin il ya plusieurs endroits on est
sûr que c'est pas le cas
les bars les restaurants les lieux de
culture
les stations de sport d'hiver parce que
c'est fermé donc il ya dix ans enfin
vous avez vu par exemple j'ai vu les
images là la foule massée dans les
centres commerciaux samedi enfin c'est
ses grands centres commerciaux que le
gouvernement a décidé de fermer les
salles hier il a eu raison samedi
c'était ouvert vous avez vu les images
qu'ils aient raison de les fermer pour
éviter justement il a raison de les
fermer mais on reporte le problème sur
les plus petits centres commerciaux il y
avait foule hier danser en plus c'était
dimanche surface et les gestes barrières
sont pas respectées dans les magasins
c'est respecter mais en dehors enfin
tout le monde peut s'en apercevoir
justin marmots sur le confinement vente
par être passé à la question du vaccin
et fabrice bruno le maire qui annonce ce
matin que les restaurateurs qui ouvre
malgré l'interdiction seront sanctionnés
risque la suspension de leur aide
et la raison de ministre de l'économie
je sais pas s'il a raison mais il faut
il faut respecter les règles
nous ce que nous ne comprenons pas c'est
que les règles ne sont pas les mêmes
pour tout le monde
waouh vous comprenez aussi qu'on
maintienne les stations de vin les
remontées mécaniques fermé non parce que
quand je vois quand je vois la foule
qui a dans les centres commerciaux je
vous le répète je pourquoi les gestes
barrière serait moins efficace en plein
air dans les stations de sports d'hiver
voilà je ne sais pas les régions
scientifique ce que la neige ça c'est
plus aptes à transmettre le virus je ne
sais pas alors de transition sur le
vaccin justement vous en parliez vous
appelez la cgt appelle à un mouvement
chez sanofi mille emplois supprimés en
tout cas une annonce de suppression de
1000 emplois 400 400 cette année mais
405 s'ajoutent à des milliers les années
précédentes à la raison un millier en
france par ailleurs pasteur qui lui
jettent l'épongé dans la course au
vaccin
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le monde de
la pharmacie en france
là il se passe plusieurs choses l'espace
il ya des gros problèmes dans la
recherche la recherche fondamentale qui
n'est pas irriguées qui n'a pas de fond
les chargements il ya les chercheurs
cherchent de l'argent avant avant de
chercher des projets c'est quand même
grave et puis on a donné carte blanche
et beaucoup d'argent à des laboratoires
privés à une main de stud sanofi en est
un bon exemple
il touche entre 100 et 120 millions par
an de crédit impôt recherche
ils suppriment des emplois ils ont des
aides sur le cic eu des exonérations de
cotisations et pour en arriver où c'est
que on est incapable par manque de
chercheurs de trouver un vaccin on va
sanofi va être là un des derniers grands
des industries à trois vaccins et et on
continue à supprimer les emplois ya un
problème il ya un vrai problème est là
le ministre de l'économie devra
intervenir en tapant un peu plus du
poing sur la table pour faire en sorte
que c'est une c'est une industrie
d'intérêt public conditionner les aides
comme on le demande pour nos entreprises
mais je crois que sanofi est un bon
exemple où on ne peut pas donner de
l'argent à une entreprise qui non
seulement licencient mais n'est pas à la
hauteur en matière de recherche et
développement et leurs vaccins comme
celui dont on a besoin et en question de
souveraineté nationale
c'est une question de souveraineté
nationale mais plus globalement autour
du vaccin c'est une question de santé
mondiale il devrait y avoir cessé ses
brevets de devrait tomber
automatiquement dans au niveau public
enfin je devenir des ddt des vaccins et
bien public des actions d'intérêt
général
parce qu'on voit bien que là aussi au
delà c'est la loi du marché qui qui
prime les les industries donne donne au
plus offrant on se retrouve un peu comme
les images qu'on avait vu au mois de
mars autour des masques ou les états
venaient acheter carrément les masques
sur les tarmacs des aéroports
c'est absolument scandaleux c'est
absolument scandaleux
sokolo oms met en place un système pour
que les pays les plus pauvres
bénéficient aussi du vaccin il ya un
accord d'ailleurs qui a été tout l'été
dernier qui avait un accueil un d'accord
aussi avec l'union européenne et on voit
que ça marche pas terrible non on manque
de vaccins au niveau des doses vous
dites on manque de vaccins dans sur la
vaccination justement
qui sera à priori ouvert dans quelques
semaines au moins de 65 ans donc
potentiellement à certains salariés
est ce que les syndicats travaillent
pour mettre en place un système de
vaccination dans les entreprises où vous
dites c'est pas le rôle des entreprises
enfin pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
discussion puisque il y à des personnes
vulnérables ou des personnes de plus de
65 ans qui sont les premiers intéressés
et on manque de vaccins nous notre
position c'est qu' évidemment il ya les
soignants aussi qui devrait être
vaccinée rapidement évidemment dès que
les doses seront arrivées ou qu'elles
seront là en compte itunes quantité
suffisante
on peut faire des vaccinations dans les
entreprises le problème c'est que on a
cassé la médecine du travail donc il y'a
pus ou d'un coup moins de pertes de
personnel soignant dans les entreprises
médecins infirmières c'est un vrai
problème y compris dans cette période où
on en parlait il ya beaucoup de risques
psychosociaux et puis il faut que cette
vaccination ne soit pas ne donnent pas
lieu à des discriminations donc il faut
du secret médical
on ne on peut imaginer des risques
diabolisme des certains employeurs qui
disent pas de vaccination pas de travail
oui il ya des liens sondage ifop qui est
parue dans le parisien le 17 janvier
dernier il ya deux semaines qui disait
que 50% des français étaient favorables
un passeport vaccinale dans les
entreprises est ce que c'est votre cas
pour l'instant
compte tenu de la situation on peut pas
parler de passeport puisque quand tout
le monde sera vaccin quand il y aura des
doses suffisantes des vaccins suffisant
on peut se poser la question aux fans
d'autres vaccins mais quelle est votre
position le jour où les français
pourront être vaccinés est ce que vous
dites oui ça ça pourrait être ça
pourrait faire l'objet d'une vaccination
obligatoire
je ne suis pas spécialiste comme
d'autres vaccins quand on est
à la naissance etc etc on a déjà délivré
de vaccination donc vaccination
obligatoire pour les salariés je vous
dis on peut imaginer oui si les
scientifiques les médecins le considère
ça peut faire partie des vaccins
obligatoires comme d'autres vaccins on
le fait pour les enfants ont la
régulièrement on l'avait compris vous
vous êtes très clairement favorable à la
vaccination vous encourager les français
à se faire vacciner pour sauver des vies
oui est ce que les syndicats doivent
jouer un rôle justement on voit qu'il ya
des français réticents est ce que les
syndicats ont un rôle à jouer pour ses
salariés en tout cas les servic signer
l'essai à la science et je pense que de
ce point de vue là on entend beaucoup de
choses
c'est au gouvernement de faire ce boulot
nous nous devons veiller à ce que les
salariés soient protégés dans les
entreprises elles vaccin fait partie de
ces protections
mais avec les réserves que je viens de
vous donnez pas de discriminations on va
parler du télétravail question qui se
pose évidemment ce moment oui le
télétravail est souhaité davantage
encore par le gouvernement on sent que
toutes les entreprises ne sont pas dans
cette logique aujourd'hui vous vous
réclamez un accord sur le télétravail
qu'est ce qui bloque aujourd'hui sont
télétravailleurs il ya il ya eu vous le
savez un soi disant accord un accord
national qui a été signé fin novembre
par tous les partenaires sociaux sauf la
cgt 1 parce que ce n'est pas un accord
contraignant ce n'est pas un accord
comme devrait l'être un accord national
qui cadrent un certain nombre de choses
quelle que soit l'entreprise où
travaille il faut il faut que sur le
télétravail levier des règles communes
parce que vous travaillez dans telle ou
telle entreprise il y a des choses qui
sont indispensables
la santé le matériel fourni si vous avez
mal au dos parce que votre chaise de
salon elle n'est pas adaptée
c'est un accident du travail ou ses de
votre responsabilité donc il faut bien
que l'entreprise fournit du matériel
adéquat il ya par exemple la
sécurisation des données
ceux qui travaillent sur des données
sensible si un virus s'il y a si
l'ordinateur est piraté qui est
responsable
le salarié parce qu'il n'a pas le
matériel adéquat où l'entreprise parce
qu'elle lui a pas fourni way et puis il
ya des indemnisations dié aux factures
d'énergie aux factures internet et c'est
donc ça l'accord que nous évoquons c'est
un accord de gré à gré ceux qui à droite
télétravail et on sait pas et puis c'est
une négociation du salarié à l'employeur
nos nouveautés tout le monde l'a signé
sur vous ben alors on a le droit de ne
pas faire des bêtises de bêtises comme
les autres et non pour vous c'était une
bêtise n'est joué car on a une position
sur le droit à la déconnexion etc
il ya de nouvelles réunions qui sont
prévues avec le gouvernement sur cette
question du tableau semble il me semble
que ce soit une visioconférence avec la
ministre du travail vous semble oui
parce que en ce moment les réunions sont
programmées sont annulés sont
reprogrammés donc je vous le dis avec
toute la prudence nécessaire qu'est ce
que vous en attendez de cette réunion
comme enfin pas grand chose pas grand
chose ces sept-là disent les décisions
se prennent
et on nous demande notre avis alors
parfois un petit peu avant parfois un
petit peu après je crois que le
gouvernement avance et puis nous on est
informé concertée c'est un nouveau un
mot à la mode c'est plus trop ce que ça
veut dire mais justement on va parler
des concertations et des concertations
la semaine dernière sur une réforme
c'est la réforme de l'assurance chômage
on al impression qu elisabeth bornes
elle est prête à la décaler cette
réforme ou en tout cas attendre que la
situation s'améliore sur le marché de
l'emploi est ce que c'est ce que vous a
dit est ce que cette réforme n'entrera
pas en vigueur le 1er avril comme prévu
faut demander au président de la
république je crois que c'est d'abord
lui qui commande est vous l'avez dit jeu
pour l'instant ce que nous comprenons
c'est que jucla pandémie se poursuit il
risque d'y avoir un nouveau décalage
avec toutes les réserves
nous ce que nous disons c'est faut
l'arrêter cette réforme y compris la
partie qui est déjà en vigueur
et puis retravaillées sur une meilleure
indemnisation du chômage
pour ceux qui sont au chômage pour les
ceux qui sont licenciés mais aussi pour
les jeunes ce complément centre est des
concessions sur ce point est ce que du
coup vous êtes très à rené gauthier mais
c'est ce qu'on demande de bondy il faut
non vous dites stop pour vous dit de
toute façon on n'en veut pas de cette
réforme
tous les syndicats le disent vers marc
et là on n'est pas tout seul c'est
important de le souligner donc quand
tous les syndicats disent la même chose
ça devrait attirer l'attention des
journalistes mais surtout du
gouvernement donc tout le monde tous les
syndicats disent stop on renégocie mais
pour améliorer améliorer l'indemnisation
du chômage enfin on cible les chômeurs
comme des privilégiés vous vous
connaissez beaucoup de jeunes qui
sortent de de la fac qui dit et qui
disent moi comme métier je veux être
chômeur moi j'en connais pas donc faut
bien faut bien régler ce problème et
notamment j insiste sur les jeunes parce
que quand on sort de l'école on n'a
droit à rien et chercher du boulot ça
coûte cher
donc ça ce sont des pistes sur
lesquelles nous voulons travailler il
faut que le gouvernement soit d'accord
je pense que le président de la
république est très doctrinaire il est
il se présente que monsieur monsieur
réforme il avait mais sans tenir compte
de la réalité enfin c'est toujours le
même problème il a un peu et on n'a pas
trop les pieds sur terre et en même
temps pour prendre une
une expression chère au moment le la
mise en place d'un chômage partiel
relativement important dans cette
période de deux crises sanitaires pour
vous c'est quand même une satisfaction
mais bien sûr que c'est une bonne chose
mais ce n'est pas une invention du
gouvernement actuel ça existe et c'est
là moi j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus vous
savez le modèle social français tant
décrié trop davantage trop de
privilégiés on voit que d'avoir même
s'il a été cassée ébréché ce modèle
socialiste on n'est pas aux états unis
un cercle quand il ya des vagues de
licenciements en gros 2 à la mise dans
une minute vous êtes viré il ya des il
ya des couvertures
il ya le chômage partiel y assurance
chômage mais je rappelle que le chômage
partiel c'est 84 % de son salaire net
vous demandez 100% vous pouvez bien sûr
vous savez qu'il ya des salariés qui
sont depuis des mois des mois avec 16 %
en moins sur leurs salaires
et quand on n'arrive pas à boucler la
fin du mois avec 100 % de son salaire
vous vous imaginez que c'est pas plus
sévère encore plus difficile avec 16 %
en moins donc oui il faut mettre la
contribution des grandes entreprises ont
parlé de sanofi ils vont verser des
dividendes à leurs actionnaires
vous trouvez que c'est normal dans la
situation vire du monde
ils touchent des aides et en plus c'est
des milliards qui donne alors eh bien
alors on pourra les mettre
on doit les mettre à contribution ses
pourrait que nous ne disons pas de
dividende aux actionnaires cette année
l'autre actualité du jour c'est le
boulot de la sécurité qui est lancée ce
matin par jean castex en cette réunion
qui vise à renforcer les moyens des
forces de l'ordre et le lien entre
police et population vous allez
participer mots non parce que la cgt
n'est pas représentative
gérald darmanin nous a pas demandé d'y
participer je vous répète ne sommes pas
représentatifs au niveau de la police
gérald darmanin a proposé à quelques
leaders syndicaux en mer jaune
je suis jus de regarder les modalités
d'une participation j'attends d'avoir
ses modalités pour répondre à gérald un
malin si je participe ou pas alors c'est
quoi vos conditions d'une transition je
veux savoir comment
qu'est ce qu'on me demande quand on vous
invite quelque part on le mieux c'est de
dire ben badi vous inviter à participer
aux tables rondes on doit doit contacter
son conseiller social pour savoir les
modalités je crois que c'est sous forme
de débat mais tous les quinze jours quel
est le sujet quels sont les sujets sur
lesquels ce que je peux dire c'est que
yves sur la sueur sur la police qui sont
des fonctionnaires
il ya des problèmes de salaires parce
que le point d'indicé est gelé depuis
dix ans
ça c'est comme à toute la fonction
publique il y a les problèmes de
conditions de travail et le problème
d'effectif
oui il faut embaucher dans la police
comme dans toutes les fonctions
publiques je pense à la santé etc
oui ça cdc des points communs et puis il
ya les besoins de moyens matériels liban
qui sont opposés à une fontaine proposer
une participation sur le principe bon
jeu dès que je connais tres que je
connais le sujet fait la nature du débat
je vous tiens au courant promis on a
compris l'autre actualité c'est le
projet recul
df qui serait scindé en trois entités
dont une 100% nucléaire est une dont le
capital serait ouvert à des
investisseurs privés ça concerne
notamment le réseau de distribution
il ya des parlementaires d'opposition
qui veulent un référendum d'initiative
partagée sur ce sujet vous les
encourager dans cette démarche
pourquoi pas mais il faut un débat
national sur cette question l'énergie
c'est bien fondamental on faisait là on
parlait des vaccins et la dure si
l'industrie pharmaceutique
demain avec une entreprise coupé
privatisée et s'il ya pénurie
d'électricité cas comment on va faire
moi je plais pdf est homogène il faut
garder la production la distribution
comme un bien public comme un bien
public et c'est pour ça que ce projet
nous le combattons en août la hausse il
ne sommes pas les seuls puisque tous les
syndicats
d'edf le combattent et avec des taux de
grévistes très important malgré le
télétravail on a atteint je crois 45% de
grévistes c'est d'autres mobilisations
qui sont prévues notamment je crois le
10 février c'est le jour de l'audition
de jean bernard lévy ici au sénat
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
à des coupures d'électricité ce jour là
est ce que ça fera partie des modes
d'action tout cas il ya des
mobilisations il ya des baisses de
charges c'est ce qu'on a constaté depuis
maintenant je crois ça fait plus d'un
mois
parce que deux mois qui ce que les
salariés sont mobilisés mais c'est qu'on
met sur le dos de la crise cité celui
sur ces coupures d'électricité qui a
fait beaucoup parlé il ya quelques temps
vous souvenez vous étiez vous même
positionné que c'était au début de
l'année contre le projet de réforme des
retraites ça pose en fait vous renvoyer
toujours la balance du côté des salariés
quand toutes les organismes vous demande
quel travail en action et 10 février je
vous réponds quand tous les syndicats
s'opposent à un projet quand ya 45 % de
taux de grévistes
malgré le télétravail etc la balle est
dans le camp des salariés ou dans le
camp du gouvernement alors on parle de
concurrence de l'europe etc et bien sûr
d'autres sujets me semble-t-il
le gouvernement peut mais sur certains
sujets le gouvernement et peut-être pas
de dire stop
on est maître chez nous et on ne veut
pas que l'énergie devienne un bien privé
et qu'on risque des coupures
vous avez raison d'en parler parce qu'un
opérateur dira vous ne payez pas assez
cher ou c'est trop compliqué d'installer
une ligne dans une zone rurale donc
débrouillez vous c'est ça qu'on veut
c'est ce qu'on vit d'ailleurs si vous me
permettez le parallèle avec le numérique
et l'internet
vous voyez il ya beaucoup d'opérateurs
privés en matière de télécommunications
vient encore des élèves des étudiants
qui sont obligés de monter dans les
arbres pour avoir de la connexion c'est
ça le bien fondé du secteur privé eh ben
il faut sacralisé des biens publics des
industries publiques et bien edf en fait
partie dernière question sur un autre
groupe fabrice et adp aéroport de paris
et oui dont la fréquentation les
aéroports c'est covè considèrent un peu
entrée s'est effondré
littéralement adp va être amené à en
tout cas proposé des mesures notamment
des réductions de 10 % du 13e mois
le g du 14e ce sont des mesures sur
lesquelles vous êtes vous êtes en mesure
de suivre ou pas il ya eu des accords de
signer je crois de l'ensemble des
syndicats
l'ensemble je précise pour pour tout le
monde parce que ça fait l'objet de
négociations ce qu'il faut parce qu'il
ya des suppressions d'emplois là qui
sont qui sont prévues par la direction
ça serait dommage de jeu je ne suis
pudique quand j ça de se réveiller dans
quelques mois en disant c'est si on
avait su on aurait pas licencier parce
qu'on a perdu du savoir faire c'est
valable dans toutes les industries dans
tous les services
et c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt que de faire de la
formation plutôt que de protéger
l'emploi
on vire pour un jour se réveillant
disant vance ait pu faire eh bien on
peut parler d' adp mais on peut parler
d'airbus de renommée sur aider mais
précisément est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
quelques efforts et en tout cas à ces
mesures proposées par la direction la
réduction de 10 des jeux les fins les
efforts il ya eu des négociations il ya
eu un accord sur la cgt s'est dit prête
à des efforts d'ailleurs mais est la cgt
a signé des accords je crois sur le sur
l'appel dès le show à l'activité
partielle de longue durée donc il ya
déjà des négociations la riba puis c'est
les salariés qui en décideront mais on a
on a atteint des limites parce que je
voulais je vous le répète il serait
dommage que pour une france qui seront
localisés qui veut se développer qui
veut créer de l'emploi
on se dise dans je ne sais pas combien
de temps va durer la pandémie dans six
mois dans un an on aurait bien aimé
pouvoir se développer mais on n'a plus
les compétences et donc faut accélérer
les de localisation on l'a on en a parlé
chez sanofi par exemple et merci
beaucoup merci de nous voir ce matin
fabrice on regarde la une de l'est
républicain ce sont les centres
commerciaux le couperet c'est à la une
delestre et prix
[Musique]